pas
bonjour bienvenue dans europe hebdo
votre rendez vous de l'actualité
européenne des chaînes parlementaires
dans cette émission direction la tunisie
le 3 mars dernier le gouvernement
tunisien a signé un accord d'association
avec l'union européenne
depuis la révolution le pays se
reconstruit peu à peu et l'europe
accompagnent ces transformations
à la clé des millions d'euros d'aidé au
développement une manière pour beaucoup
d'acheter la participation active des
forces tunisiennes dans le contrôle des
frontières
mais d'abord l'actualité après des mois
de négociations l'accord sur l'union
bancaire est scellé mais dans les fêtes
il ne sera véritablement opérationnel
que dans quelques années alors est-ce un
accord en trompe l'oeil c'est la
question de la semaine avec simon
barbarie
la nuit a été longue très longue
16 heures de négociations marathon pour
accoucher du texte le mécanisme de
résolution des crises financières le
dernier pilier de l'union bancaire est
né alléluia un succès énorme pour le
président du parlement martin schulz un
peu de triomphalisme pour rappeler le
rôle essentiel des eurodéputés à
quelques semaines des élections
européennes
ça ne fait pas de mal la bataille a
pourtant été rude entre le parlement la
commission et des représentants du
conseil européen
alors c'est quoi l'union bancaire un
fonds de résolution de 55 milliards
d'euros financés par les banques pour
éviter aux états de mettre la main au
portefeuille pour sauver les mauvais
élèves de la finance mais un bémol il ne
sera effectif que dans huit ans donc si
une banque d'un état membre fait
faillite
entre temps ce sera une fois de plus aux
pays membres de jouer au pompier alors
une eau bancaires un accord en trompe
l'oeil
et pour évoquer ce dossier de l'union
bancaire ces lignes bête que je reçois
aujourd'hui bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ces lignes vous êtes
journaliste à l'agencé france presse au
bureau de bruxelles et vous êtes
spécialiste des questions économiques
vous avez suivi ce dossier de l'union
bancaire alors finalement est ce qu on
nous enfume sur cette histoire est ce
que on est vraiment sorti d'affaires je
pense pas qu on nous enfume je pense pas
non plus qu'on soit vraiment sorti
d'affaires alors nous enfume pas parce
que c'est un bloc très important de la
construction européenne qui s'est mis en
place en moins de deux ans depuis le
début de la propos depuis que la
proposition a été mise sur la table de
ce mécanisme de d'union bancaire et
c'est très rapide au regard du rythme
législatif européen habituel donc on
sent qu'il y avait quand même une
volonté et des états et du parlement
d'avancer sur ce dossier parce qu'elle
est une urgence maintenant pour autant
évidemment on n'est pas sorti d'affaires
parce qu'effectivement comme comme on
l'a moins vu dans le petit sujet il va
falloir du temps pour que ce fonds qui
va permettre de venir en aide aux
banques sans sans que les contribuables
sont sollicités il va effectivement pas
fonctionné tout de suite en tout cas
l'occasion temps et l'allemagne poussait
pour celui qui envoie là oui l'allemagne
et l'allemagne voulaient voulais que ce
soit disant le parlement voulait que ce
soit trois ans finalement c'est pas tout
à fait une cote mal taillée c'est plutôt
l'allemagne qui a gagné dans ce dossier
en en acceptant les huit ans mais voilà
huit ans c'est quand même une longue
période alors qu'est ce qui se passe si
une banque fait faillite comme on l'a
connu en 2008 enfin fait faillite fin
fait défaut si je puis dire dans les
huit ans qu'est ce qui va se passer
alors entre temps ce qui va aussi être
mis en place et qui est très important
c'est ce qu'on appelle le bel hymne
bellens et c'est encore une fois un
mécanisme plus large que celui là qui
permet de dire ce sont les banques qui
vont payer en priorité pour sauver les
banques et non pas les compter les
électeurs et donc dans un premier temps
les actionnaires de la banque ses écrits
entiers vont devoir être sollicités en
premier lieu et ensuite ce fonds qui de
toute façon commencera à être abondé à
partir de 2016
donc à partir de 1 an ou deux ans il y
aura déjà de l'argent dans ce fonds
et si c'est insuffisant alors là oui on
fera appel aux états et si les états
n'en ont pas les moyens
alors là on fera appel à des fonds
européens public et donc ça pourrait
être le mécanisme européen de stabilité
ce fameux pare feu de la zone euro qui a
été effectivement voté et qui est de
plus de 500 milliards d'euros
donc effectivement ça veut dire que la
puissance publique restera un parties
prenantes dans le sauvetage des banques
si si les fonds sont insuffisants tout
dépend évidemment de la taille de la
banque ou des banques qui font défaut
justement parce que là en fait on parle
d'un fond donc abondé par les banques
savent bailin donc qui permettrait donc
aux banques de payer pour les banques
les ont pas d'infos 55 milliards d'euros
oui ça paraît si c'est pas une goutte
d'eau mais ça paraît peu
bon c'est un début mais c'est surtout un
peu aussi une garantie c'est quelque
chose qui est là pour rassurer rassurer
les marchés rassurés le secteur
financier et rassuré en gros oui les
marchés mondiaux céline est ce que pour
vous c'est un bon accord comme tous les
accords c'est un compromis un compromis
qui a été difficile qui a été difficile
à obtenir en deux temps d'abord entre
les états eux mêmes et dont on a
beaucoup dit que c'était un conte
premier allemand de fait l'allemagne a
obtenu beaucoup de ce qu'elle demandait
c'est à dire une certaine lenteur dans
la mise en oeuvre et c est après il ya
eu un compromis avec le parlement qui a
été aussi très difficile à dire puisque
le parlement a voulu montrer qu'il
n'était pas la dernière roue du carrosse
et qu'il avait son mot à dire dans cette
affaire et a voulu faire en sorte que ce
mécanisme ne soient plus efficaces
qu'ils ne l'étaient dans la proposition
initiale
donc comme tous les compromis il n'est
pas parfait et il existe et voilà il est
en tout cas il existe et si le texte est
voté à la prochaine session papale à la
ministation de celle de demi avril et
donc voilà le job a été facile mais
effectivement comme tous les compromis
ne satisfait pas tout le monde
alors je voudrais que on se tourne vers
l'italie alors si vous n'êtes pas censé
savoir mais peut-être que vous le savez
matteo renzi après la tête du conseil il
y a quelques semaines et il a annoncé en
l'espace de quinze jours
pléthore en fait de réductions d'impôts
et d'un plan de relance assez assez
important et il était
quelques heures après son intronisation
à berlin je voudrais qu'on écoute
l'italie doit arrêter de penser que nous
faisons ces réformes à cause de
bruxelles ou berlin ou une autre
capitale
nous faisons ces réformes car elles sont
bonnes pour nous matteo renzi qui
annonce des milliards d'euros comme sa
sortie tout droit dont on ne sait pas
trop où est ce que bruxelles si je puis
dire et
et plutôt confiante quant à sa capacité
de réduire les déficits bruxelles pour
l'instant par rapport à ces annonces de
matteo renzi s'est montré prudent fin
barroso le commissaire chargé des
affaires économiques olli rehn se sont
montrés prudents très diplomate en
disant qu'ils avaient confiance dans le
fait que l'italie allait respecter ses
objectifs en matière de déficits
donc maintenant reste à savoir si
effectivement ça va être le cas r'n'b a
promis qu'il respecterait les
engagements budgétaires par rapport à
bruxelles
donc maintenant on va le juger sur les
résultats ce qu'il espère lui son pari
c'est de dire en injectant des milliards
dans l'économie et notamment pour
relancer la consommation
ça va permettre de relancer aussi
l'économie italienne la production etc
et donc ça va faire naître de la
croissance et donc c'est bon pour les
finances publiques bon est-ce qu'il va
gagner son pari pour l'instant personne
ne peut le dire
et la commission européenne ne peut pas
le dire non plus il ya quelques semaines
le parlement européen a rendu un rapport
qui a été adopté en commission
économique et
et qui a été voté donc en session sur la
troïka donc la troïka je rappelle que
c'est la bce le fmi et la commission
européenne et sur son action dans les
pays qui ont été donc pris en charge
le rapport est catastrophique pour cette
action sachant que c'est un rapport en
fait qui finalement est à ce qu'on
appelle ici un rapport d'initiative donc
il n'y a pas de dimension légale si je
puis dire à quoi ça sert d'avoir ce type
de rapport qui est rendu ça sert je
pense que c'est une démarche politique
de la part des parlementaires qui
consiste à montrer que ils sont pas
contents de la façon dont se dotant se
sont déroulées les choses avec la troîka
parce que à leurs yeux c'est pas une
institution démocratique parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas de
contrôle elle n'a pas été mise en place
il ya aucun contrôle du parlement et
c'est ce qu'il souhaiterait à l'avenir
elle n'a pas été mise en place avec non
plus le contrôle des parlements
nationaux des pays concernés
oui il parle carrément d'autocratie
post-démocratique assez fort donc étant
donné que ça s'est fait très vite dans
l'urgence et que bon ce sont des
institutions qui ont l'habitude qui ont
beaucoup d'expérience pour traiter ce
genre de sujet on les a laissé faire on
leur a laissé la bride sur le cou le
parlement ça ne lui convient pas il le
fait savoir juste avant les élections
parlementaires européennes parce que il
veut montrer que il a il a envie
d'intervenir dans cette danseuse et
voilà il veut être dans le jeu et ne pas
qu'ils appellent un ce rapport à la
création d'un fonds monétaire européen
est ce qu'on peut espérer un jour
quelque chose de cet ordre c'est encore
assez vague
à ce stade et c'est quelque chose à long
terme ils le disent eux-mêmes donc pour
l'instant je pense que c'est pas à
l'ordre du jour
et que la troïka va rester là encore un
petit moment donc on réalisera encore
d'autres problématiques d'une tipp
austérité à outrance selon vous en tout
cas peut-être que le fmi lui-même et la
commission reconnaisse que peut-être
l'austérité à outrance maintenant mais
ce n'est pas la meilleure solution
toujours est il que en tout cas les
programmes qu'ils ont appliqué jusqu'ici
et qui continuent d'appliquer pour la
grèce portugal irlande sont assez assez
drastiques donc pour l'instant on en est
encore là où il a écouté merci ceni pour
ses explications vous nous avez éclairer
sur ces dossiers nous on continue
direction la tunisie trois ans après la
chute de ben ali le pays tente peu à peu
de se reconstruire et ce avec l'aide de
l'union européenne dans l'est dans la
banlieue de tunis les travaux financés
par les fonds de l'europe sont légion
mais tout ceci est semble-t-il à un coût
notamment celui du contrôle des
frontières c'est un reportage à tunis de
paul bouffard et de hamdi qui lie
c'est un pays qui se remet d'une
révolution sur tunis
il flotte un air de liberté
la nouvelle constitution politique est
fraîchement signé et dans la banlieue on
s'active à la reconstruction
tous les notables locaux sont là et un
français le représentant de l'union
européenne il vient contrôler
l'avancement des travaux
vérifier si les fonds communautaires
destinés à la tunisie sont bien reversé
sur le terrain vous avez démarré quand
car ici l'union européenne est
investisseur des dons plusieurs millions
d'euros par quartier pour rénover
développer les zones défavorisées du
grand tunis
c'est la plus grosse commune du grand
tunis donc dans le pur dans le projet là
sur les 120 quartiers qui sont en train
d'être habilité en a une moyenne de 2
millions d'euros par quartier depuis le
début de la révolution
l'europe double son assistance
financière à la tunisie 480 millions
d'euros les fonds européens sont
utilisés pour améliorer leurs conditions
de vie en france ce sont des terrains
agricoles à l'origine on imaginer les
gens marchent dans la boue il n'y a pas
d'eau potable il n'y a pas d'électricité
en quelques mois un là ici c'est les
travaux qui dure neuf mois en quelques
mois leur environnement vraiment change
non seulement pour l'habitat non
seulement pour leurs enfants mais
également pour ce qui est de promotion
d'activités économiques
ces panneaux jaunes au sigle de l'union
il en pousse un peu partout mais quand
les officiels ont disparu la rue elle ne
voit pas tout en rose
même si si le bitume et refait à neuf
sur le trottoir d'en face l'argent on
n'en voit pas la couleur
il ya de l'argent qui vient de l'europe
1 ça se voit pas il ya beaucoup de
voleurs parce que benali le grand voleur
et reste 40 voilà maintenant et reste
lien ici la misère moi je pense que
l'union européenne devrait venir plus
souvent pour superviser et coordonner
les projets je dois venir directement au
lieu d'utiliser un intermédiaire comme
le gouvernement tunisien ont fait en
tout cas c'est mon avis accompagner ce
pays
c'est l'objectif d'une mine garelli le
fonctionnaire européen est responsable
de l'afrique du nord pour le service
européen d'action extérieure
selon lui il faut rénover l'économie à
condition que le développement soit
local qu'ils retiennent les tunisiens
chez eux
le 3 mars un accord de mobilité est
signé objectif faciliter l'immigration
régulière pour mieux contrôler les
frontières
alors ces investissements européens une
incitation caché à l'immigration choisie
donc je crois que c'est un projet plus
ambitieux qui ne se réduit pas son volet
sécuritaire mais qui vise encore une
fois à mieux gérer les flux migratoires
dans l'intérêt des deux parties
la tunisie au mieux au rang de gardes
frontières de l'union européenne
mokhtar trifi n'est pas dupe et il y
voit un moyen d'acheter la fin de
l'immigration clandestine vers l'europe
lorsqu'il s'agit de commerce on oblige
on exige que la liberté soit assurée la
liberté de commercer la liberté
d'investir la liberté 2 2
de pomper les richesses de la tunisie ça
n'a pas de problème on n'a pas à
s'opposer à ça mais le simple citoyen
tunisien qui veut aller en europe même
pour le tourisme il n'a pas le droit
s'il n'est pas universitaire ou
hautement qualifiés trois ans après la
révolution de jasmin ici rien n'a
vraiment changé surtout dans les cités
populaires celles qui ont poussé benali
hors du pays et chams en est un symbole
à 21 ans quand ce jeune tunisien regarde
son quartier il n'a plus d'espoir
l'europe seule échappatoire
le jeune homme a déjà tenté plusieurs
fois la traversée
oui à la télévision ils nous ont dit
qu'on allait avoir de l'argent du
travail
je sais pas pour nous tout ça c'est pas
pour nos quartiers pauvres et les riches
qui vont profiter nous dans nos
quartiers on n'a rien on voit rien c'est
pour ça que je veux quitter la tunisie
il y a deux mois
sa dernière tentative aurait pu tourner
au drame chez naf et flo là d'un foie je
suis parti sur une barque on était 60
personnes dessus mais normalement peut
être 25 personnes maximum en pleine mer
on est tombé en panne
on était entre la vie et la mort il y
avait des enfants il y avait des femmes
la police est venue nous a ramenés en
tunisie on a été mis en prison à tunis
pendant quelques jours et voilà je suis
de nouveau à la casse des charges et un
robinet de la pause c'est moche c'est
banal
peu importe le prix ou même le danger
chams de s'installer en france
il n'attend qu'une chose dans les
prochaines heures un coup de téléphone
de son passeur
monde
et voilà pour ce reportage à tunis de
paul bouffard et ses magnifiques images
pour évoquer cette question de cet
accord d'association entre l'union
européenne et la tunisie est la
contrepartie marie-christine derrière
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes députée
européenne membre du parti de la gauche
unitaire européenne et monsieur tahar
chérif vous êtes ambassadeur de tunisie
auprès de l'union européenne de la
belgique et du luxembourg
marie-christine là je me tournerai à
vous d'abord quand vous voyez ce
témoignage de ce jeune homme qui
n'attend qu'une chose c'est de ce coup
de fil en fait de son passeur est ce
qu'on n'a pas échoué quelque part en
tunisie
j'ai envie de dire l'union européenne
n'a pas été à la hauteur de l'espoir
dégagée par ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler la révolution arabe
le printemps du jasmin
quand
il ya eu cette révolte populaire qui a
chassé monsieur ben ali du pouvoir il ya
un immense espoir qui s'est dégagée en
tunisie on oublie trop souvent que les
causes étaient d'abord des causes
sociales
je pense notamment à la place contenu
dans cette révolution les jeunes
diplômé et on leur a promis s'est dit
dans le reportage d'ailleurs de leur
venir en aide avec beaucoup d'argent
oh mais en fait on a l'impression
d'ailleurs les européens sont persuadés
qu'on a versé des milliards sur la
tunisie pour pour les et les millions
d'euros ans oui il ya des
infrastructures alors effectivement
n'arrive pas partout mais ça sera ma
deuxième question je dis on n'a pas été
à la hauteur parce que d'abord l'argent
est arrivé tard on a perdu trois ans
parce que l'union européenne au delà de
beaux discours n'a pas été à la hauteur
de la demande des tunisiens et que si je
vais vous donner un seul élément pour
comprendre depuis le départ de monsieur
bennani jusqu'aujourd'hui la tête de la
dette tunisienne a augmenté ça veut dire
qu'on a aidé entre guillemets la tunisie
d'abord à coups de presse à coups de
prêts et aux conditions du fmi
quand vous avez des interlocuteurs qui
vous disent que l'argent ils n'ont pas
l'impression d'en voir la couleur donc
ces millions d'euros qui sont donnés par
l'europe où va l'argent de l'union
européenne en tunisie
oui le doit plus précisément dans le
documentaire exemple 10 480 millions
d'euros
en réalité depuis 2011 jusqu'en 2013
jusqu'à fin 2013 ses 445 millions
d'euros qui sont allés pour la
gouvernance et que akon économique la
compétitivité et la convergence avec lui
et l'appui aux zones défavorisées
si on dit ça c'est en 2011 en 2012
également gouvernance économique et
développement durable
donc en gros vous ne vous nous dites que
cet argent il a été directement sur le
terrain est ce que vous êtes d'accord
depuis depuis toujours depuis toujours
je pense parce que même si la famille de
ben ali s'est enrichie oui mais ça
c'était avant 2011 mais depuis 2011 on
nous dit de 445 millions ou est-ce
qu'ils sont passés est ce que vous avez
est-ce que probablement un contrôle sur
l'utilisation de ces fonds ils le
demandent
c'est déjà une bonne demande et c'est
dit
c'est vrai c'est vrai pour toutes les
aides européennes
c'est vrai y compris à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne d'ailleurs pour les
aides de l'union européenne vis-à-vis
des mets des états membres l'essentiel
des aides passe par les gouvernements et
on est sans arrêt en discussions avec
les gouvernements et on se demande
toujours si l'argent arrive exactement
là où on veut monsieur l'ambassadeur le
dit le dit très bien dans les propos
gouvernance économique qu'est ce qu'on
met derrière gouvernance économique
je pense que la question essentielle
c'est pas à la gouvernance économique
c'est la question sociale comment on
aide avec des projets locaux
je vais vous donner un exemple je suis
pas une fan de ce système je trouve que
l'allemagne en l'espèce a très bien agi
l art en convertit une partie de sa
dette
en projet de développement local en
projet de développement de cage
c'est comme un oui mais beaucoup plus
tard et ça serait important que la
france en fasse beaucoup plus parce que
la france est un des principaux
créanciers de la tuque la tunisie et
elle aurait pu faire beaucoup d'efforts
pour transformer sa dette en des projets
effectivement sur le terrain
monsieur l'ambassadeur
vous avez donc sur la tunisie a signé un
accord d'association de 3 mars dernier
l'idée aussi c'est le membre du service
d'action extérieure qui représente
l'union européenne en tunisie le dit
bien l'idée est aussi de contrôler les
frontières est ce que vous êtes devenu
le garde frontières de l'europe
non pas du tout mais c'est une manière
de coopérer avec l'union européenne
parce que moi même en tant que
responsable je n'aime pas que les jeunes
et seulement deux choix ou bien se jeter
à la mer ou bien aller faire la guerre
en syrie je voudrais que vous répondiez
est ce que vous êtes devenu le garde
frontières de l'union européenne en
passionnant mais ça dure à une
coopération renforcée avec l'union
européenne
mais pour nous il s'agit d'abord de
garantir la dignité des jeunes tunisiens
parce que il ya des projets les pays
signataires d'air pourquoi c'est pas
tous les pays qui ont signé avec nous
cette déclaration politique sur la
mobilité c'est seulement débit ils ont
fait des propositions concrètes
notamment la création de centres de
formation professionnelle et puis a
également et on n'a pas encore signé un
accord c'est juste une déclaration
politique qui n'est pas contraignant
mais il va y avoir des négociations pour
désaccord un accord de réadmission et un
accord de facilitation de visa donc ce
qui permettra effectivement peut-être
aux tunisiens de fonctionner afin de
circuler plus facilement vous êtes
d'accord d'un questionnaire non non
jouer s'il fallait encore parce que je
comprends que monsieur l'ambassadeur dit
ça je comprends que la tunisie se bat
pour sa lettre le gouvernement tunisien
se bat pour ça mais cet accord de
mobilité il se situe dans une politique
globale de l'union européenne au
parlement européen on sait bien parce
que c'est le septième accord depuis que
le parlement européen a maintenant un
droit d'agrément ou de veto sur ces ce
type d'accord que nous sommes saisis
d'un
d'un projet de ce genre il ya
effectivement toujours un accord de
réadmission et un accord de
libéralisation des visas
l'accord de réadmission c'est
effectivement le rôle de gendarme de
l'union européenne que l'on veut faire
jouer à ces pays-là la turquie la
tunisie le maroc principalement
il suffit de lire le texte même de
l'accord on va renforcer les moyens de
la tunisie pour qu'elle accueille
dignement les demandeurs d'asile
mais ces demandeurs d'asile ils veulent
venir en union européenne il ya un
principe de non-refoulement l'union
européenne vingt-trois mille tunisiens
sont venus à rome en europe pourquoi
parce qu'il y avait une interdiction qui
existe toujours d'ailleurs la loi n'a
toujours pas été modifiées d'émigrer
pour les tunisiens
et pendant ce temps là pendant qu on
hurlait en france sur l'invasion des
vingt-trois mille tunisiens la tunisie
accueillait six cent mille réfugiés
libyens
six cent mille insurgés libyens dans
lequel les gouvernements français et
anglais était un parti prenante au
conflit
donc moi je salue ce conseil ce qu'a
fait le peuple tunisien à ce moment là
alors justement à ce propos il est l'un
des intervenants du reportage donc le
jeune homme que l'on a vu à la fin qu'il
y avait une question directe à vous
poser on l'écouté
allez vous essayer nous si on est
valable au travail
gardez nous essayer nous pour six mois
au moins senti mal à ma fille moi je
suis prêt à travailler sur les chantiers
dans le bâtiment n'importe où on veut
bien de moi des musiques mattrach vous
consoler et enchaîner à l'air a donné tu
attaques
pourquoi c'est pas comme en algérie ou
au maroc
ils obtiennent plus facilement des visas
que nous pourquoi
c'est à la villa la série animal qu'est
ce qui est à la racine
monsieur l'ambassadeur est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas effectivement permettre à
ces jeunes tunisiens qui ne trouvent pas
de travail de venir en europe pour
occuper des postes que pour l'instant on
a du mal à à pourvoir
j'avais la décision ne dépend pas des
autorités tunisiennes se vendent les
autorités des états de l'union
européenne
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à leur
demander justement d'ouvrir vous via les
accords de réadmission mais est ce que
on peut pousser à ce que cette cette
immigration si je puis dire choisis
soient mises en oeuvre
il ya eu un accord qui a été signé il ya
quelques années avec avec la france où
il ya 70 métiers c'est si les besoins de
la france
malheureusement cet accord prévoit 9000
les migrants par an entre migrants dix
ans pour une période bien déterminée des
migrants 6 unis mais ça ne marche pas
pourquoi ça ne marche pas parce que ya
pas eu diffusion de cet accord auprès
des préfectures ou des entreprises
françaises qui ont besoin d'une certaine
si l'on considère mais derrière de san
siro avant d'autoriser dans voilà c'est
un peu ça dans le dos en quelques années
on a réalisé que 2000 à 3000 cas c'est
ça s'appelle accord de migration
concertée gestion gestion de la
migration concertée du malheureusement
ça n'a pas marché
on a essayé de dupliquer ça avec
d'autres pays tels que l'italie ou
l'allemagne
mais maintenant les efforts sont
concentrés sur ce qu'on appelle la
migration circulaire
l'allemagne l'a fait d'ailleurs à la
recruté dernièrement des ingénieurs et
des infirmiers en gros les élites
tunisienne dont l'europe a besoin oui on
peut dire ça mais papa pas seulement les
élites 1 dans le tourisme y a
il ya beaucoup de besoins dans le
domaine de la santé a beaucoup de
besoins
on connaît un peu la pyramide des âges
du de nos pays et la pyramide des âges
depuis on aime après en europe donc il
ya des besoins notamment en matière
d'accompagnement des gens du troisième
âge
mce synergia ce sera ma dernière
question est-ce qu'il faut favoriser ce
type d'immigration choisie
moi je suis pour qu'on favorise
l'immigration choisie je pense que
l'union européenne abe a besoin des
migrants aujourd'hui on est un peu dans
une situation particulière en france
parce qu'on est un des rares pays de
l'union européenne à avoir un taux demi
de démographie positive on oublie qu'on
le doit aux migrants d'ailleurs en
grande partie pas seulement je veux
faire un petit laïus féministe là la
france est le pays de l'union européenne
avec l'irlande qui a le taux de
reproduction le plus important oui mais
la france est la seule qui a le taux de
natalité le plus important est le taux
de travail des femmes le plus important
c'est la france est un modèle entre
guillemets sur l'activité l'activité des
femmes mais néanmoins sans l'apport des
migrants
notre on n'aurait pas une balance
démographique aussi positif mais la
plupart des pays de l'union européenne
sont dans la démarche inverse
donc on a besoin de ces populations on a
besoin de ces populations et j'avais
envie de dire à ceux à ce jeune homme d
accord de courte durée pour les besoins
de courte durée c'est ça qui est dans
l'accord il n'y a que ça moi je fais des
saisonniers exactement c'est en fonction
des besoins de l'union européenne moi je
pense que l'immigration est une richesse
que les échanges entre les populations
du nord et du sud sont des richesses on
à apprendre les uns des autres on n'est
pas dans on n'est pas dans un
partenariat en réalité l'union
européenne continue de regarder les pays
du sud comme si c'étaient ses anciennes
colonies
mais le dire de façon elle prend ce dont
elle a besoin d'aucun d'euros selon vous
il faut réussir à mettre en place un
système de donnant donnant qui soit pas
seulement basé sur de la réadmission
mais aussi non bien sûr quand on regarde
quand on interroge les migrants eux
mêmes la migration circulatoire
circulaire en tant que tel - jeu ça me
choque pas à ce que les populations les
migrants eux mêmes ils ont envie d'aller
et de venir
mais en réalité c'est le contraire qu'on
fait on l'est on l'est on les oblige
toutes les politiques de l'union
européenne et notamment les politiques
de la france en ce moment c'est on les
accueille est fait pour notamment les
étudiants les trucs et puis après s'ils
repartent ils savent qu'ils ne pourront
pas revenir s'ils étaient sûrs de
pouvoir aller
comment on aurait moins de difficulté et
ça se passerait beaucoup mieux
d'ailleurs ça ne se passe pas si mal
vous en ai qu une preuve éclatante
charmed
merci on terminera cette émission sur
seconde merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à cette émission nous c'est
terminé
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles actualités européenne à
bientôt
où